[Music]
20 year old Kylie Jenner has clearly hid
the beauty bank but it's how she did it
that crowned her one of America's
richest self-made women on the Forbes
cover I knew I was passionate about
makeup but I didn't know I could have
fun every day doing my job
I had an insecurity with my lips when I
was younger so I turned to makeup to
help me feel more confident
I just want my lips to look fuller
everything else just kind of fell into
place
Kylie became worth nine hundred million
in less than three years
compare that to big sister Kim who's
worth 350 mil how'd she do it it started
with this $29 lip kit the key don't make
too much cuz not being able to get it
just makes people want it more all
15,000 kit sold out in less than a
minute the 20 year old also post selfies
almost every hour captioning of course
what makeup she's wearing momager Kris
handles the business side and takes a
10% cut of everything
she is my goals she's definitely been a
huge part of the success of Kylie
cosmetics et has been with Kylie since
the beginning you know before the
headline-making
lip fillers the wigs and the booty who
does your mom say is her favorite child
Kim she says I am like secretly but
publicly she says Kim is then just six
months before she launches the near
billion-dollar makeup line
Kylie told us her inspiration everyone
wants to see like my makeup tips and
when I do with my hair and this and that
so I just want to do like tutorials and
what I use is there any post that you've
posted that you kind of regret or you're
like only if I post like the wrong
selfie and I'm like that other selfie
was so much better than that selfie and
ask for Kylie's secret for success if I
could give some advice let's do
something that you love so you just have
fun every day and you love what you do
[Music]